what's poppin rockstars my name is mt
and james gunn has been betrayed
that's right everybody the cast of james
gunn's upcoming suicide squad movie has
leaked
the trailer for all of us greedy nerds
to see and hot damn am i excited for
this movie because it for sure
looks like a crazy fun time and the
suicide squad movie
that we should have got you know several
years ago but anyways let's get into it
gang
blood sport robert dubois robert dubois
in prison for putting superman in the
icu with a kryptonite bullet that's
bloodsport man hey
i hope they show that
[Music]
my court date is coming up
oh [__]
this gives me deadshot vibes
[Music]
i wouldn't take such extreme measures
this isn't the first time amanda
waller's
had that happen probably are you in or
out
yo you look shook let's start bush sport
is shook
each member has chosen for his or her
own completely unique set of abilities
oh my god rat catcher he's a rap
hey guys sorry i'm late i had to go
number two
what's up girls poop in the dc universe
that's good
i'm gonna go with afghan wow it's
clearly
27 kids that weasel's gunner
james gunn oh they directly reference
marvel
every trace of something known only as
project starfish
starfish is a slang term for a butthole
no harley quinn used her starfish to do
number two earlier
all right peter capaldi
oh my god i love king shark
wow ah that makes me so happy to see
polka dot man happen
oh my i can't wait to see that scene
i'm going to get you out of here it's
true rat catcher is the main character
and the most powerful
gotta say i'm not biased
oh my god james james gunn
james
i love how king shark has like a groot
angle there like they're going for like
a grudish thing because
who doesn't like brew and like oh man
king shark's gonna be
amazing but of course my favorite
character in this whole movie has got to
be rat catcher
and her freaking rat with a backpack on
waving at me
like come on come on get me 17
rat catcher figures are you kidding me
wow so that was a really great trailer i
am genuinely excited for this movie
because i love everything james gunn
uh because that man is a brilliant
brilliant man
and like did you see king shark being
absolutely handled by starro like i
don't know what's going on in that
scenario
how he got attached to the tentacle of a
starfish but
man it just this movie looks like a wild
wild
ride and i also love how the trailer
starts off with bloodsport cleaning like
what looks to be gum on the ground like
a red piece of gum i think that's
supposed to be symbolic of
a blood drop and i really love how
they're going with the whole bloodsport
shot superman type deal in this movie
because it is the coolest thing about
bloodsport like he literally has
kryptonite bullets and he wants to shoot
superman like i hope they show us a
flashback of that in the movie sort of
like we had a flashback with deadshot in
the original suicide squad movie when he
interacted with batman so it'd be cool
to have
a secret henry cavill cameo here but
before i continue i want to make sure to
thank
bang energy for sponsoring this video
here we go
i feel the energy coursing through my
veins every can of bang energy has zero
calories
zero carbs zero sugar and zero
artificial colors
every 16 ounce can contains 300
milligrams of caffeine
super creatine coq10 and branched chain
amino acids i'm sipping on the cotton
candy flavor right now and it is
literally just like cotton candy it's
it's liter the liquid form of cotton
candy
it brings me into the past during the
days when my mother used to bring me to
the carnival
mother can you please buy me some cotton
candy no mt
you've had too much already listen i
drink a bang when i need to pick me up
in the morning or when i need to plow
through a long video
and want my mind to be alert check out
bang on instagram
and get 10 off of your order at bang
energy.com
when you use the code new rockstars 10.
there you can buy a variety pack of bang
energy or just buy a 12 pack
of your favorite flavor like peach mango
lemon drop
or rainbow unicorn if you're feeling
magical on the inside
i know i am use the code new rockstars
10 and receive 10
off of your bang energy order that is
code new
rockstars 10 for 10 off and speaking of
deadshot bloodsport literally gives me
hardcore
deadshot vibes especially with the whole
daughter angle that they're going with
this movie because
if you remember in suicide squad one
dudshot's daughter was a big
motivation for deadshot and pushed him
towards wanting to be a better person
and all that stuff and when waller is
talking to bloodsport he seems generally
concerned about what waller tells him to
get him to not stab her in the throat
with the pen
and it probably has to do with the fact
that starro is a global threat and could
threaten his daughter so he's like
you know what i was gonna stab you but
yeah let's let's let's save the world
let's do that
and there's if there's one character i
really do genuinely care about in this
movie it's polka dot man because he
seems very depressed
like the promo material paints this man
as a very depressed man but in this
trailer
we see that he's happy to be a superhero
or to feel like a superhero with a
suicide squad which is like oh
this is nice he gets to feel happy for
once
doing you know polka dot things so that
makes me happy and of course we gotta
talk about weasel what the hell is going
on with weasel's whole
existence not only does he look like a
freak but he killed 27
children that's a lot of like that's 27
more children than one should kill in
one's lifetime
i have to say so weasel's probably a
goner because wb can't really redeem
a child murderer so weasel's probably
gone early in the film
i would assume and what's really cool
here is that dc directly references
guardians of the galaxy
which is insane to me because they
usually don't talk about each other dc's
over here
marvel's over here so it's just like
well they really want people to see this
movie but what's interesting to me is
that walder says that the main mission
of the suicide squad is to destroy
any trace of a project called project
starfish which is of course a reference
to stara who is a major antagonist of
this film and a giant ass kaiji with a
starfish that you know was the star of
the last trailer no pun intended
but this has me thinking is waller
trying to cover up her tracks is project
starfish actually something that waller
and her people were working on in the
past
but now has grown you know out of
control and then like they have to like
cover up their tracks because that's
what waller does
waller does not care she just she'll
murder anybody she's probably gonna
murder all of her co-workers like she
did in the first movie but yeah this
movie looks like an insane ride on the
crazy bus and i'm all about
it so august 6 literally cannot come any
sooner but we are gonna do a more
in-depth breakdown of this trailer very
soon so keep a lookout for that because
there are a lot of really
neat stuff and a lot of new pieces of
information that have popped up that we
gotta
you know analyze and you know speculate
because we're the speculation nation you
know what i mean you know what i mean so
yeah keep an eye on that breakdown of
the suicide squad trailer coming out on
thursday
and then following that on friday eric
will be dropping an episode three
breakdown for loki so keep your eyes
peeled on the rockstars by subscribing
to new rockstars and hitting the
notification bell and be sure to hit up
newrockstarsmerch.com because we have a
lot of cool low-key [__]
on sale like our new loki latest
obsession shirt that looks super cool
and you need to be wearing it
so your friends can think you are cool
as well anyways thank you for watching
this video i'll catch you guys later
[Music]
tata
you